hello hello I'm Flavia
his name is Rodolfo we're from são
leopoldo Rio Grande su Brazil our
great-great grandparents came from
Germany that's why I speak German and
why we enjoy travelling in Germany today
we're in Rostock this lovely old
Hanseatic city and we'd like to show it
to you yes that's Agatha
that's at the Town Hall is a very
beautiful building the arcades are also
extremely beautiful but over here
there's something very important
not you see this is it it's the snake
there are lots of legends about it but
the most important one is that if you
stroke its head it will bring you good
luck
I have feel feel
this is the or disappear this is the
University look at the facade it's
lovely it's a third oldest university in
Germany
yeah Bruna the fountain is called draw
de vivre it's very beautiful here look
at the clock up there it's very unusual
I'm sick what do you know
he is there it is we're going in now
that's insane oh this is an old
restaurant and a kaga is a car an old
sailing ship
yes India we've come to the end of our
tour of Rostock it's been a lovely day
we've seen lots of things the Marine
Kevin the University the town hall and
all sorts of things and I hope you come
here sometime and get to know this
beautiful city oh wow
here hair Coleman on the finished at
Kenan land cheese